.
>> THANK YOU, IMTIAZ TYAB
REPORTING FROM ISRAEL.
>>> MULTIPLE SOURCES TELL CBS
NEWS THAT COLONIAL PIPELINE PAID
A MULTIMILLION DOLLAR RANSOM TO
THE HACKERS WHO CRIPPLED THE
NETWORK LEAVING MANY GAS PUMPS
DRY IN THE SOUTHEAST.
THE PIPELINE WHICH STRETCHES
FROM TEXAS TO NEW JERSEY IS BACK
ON LINE, BUT IT WILL TAKE
SEVERAL MORE DAYS TO RETURN TO
NORMAL.
SENIOR INVESTIGATIVE
CORRESPONDENT, THAT'S CATHERINE
HERRIDGE, IS FOLLOWING THE
STORY.
THERE IS CONCERN THAT BY PAYING
THE RANSOM SOME WILL ENCOURAGE
OTHER ATTACKS.
HAVE WE HEARD ANYTHING FROM THE
HACKERS?
>> Reporter: WELL, GOOD MORNING.
WE HAVEN'T HEARD MORE FROM THE
HACKERS.
ITS PAGE ON THE DARK WEB IS
APPARENTLY DOWN, AND IT'S NOT
CLEAR WHETHER IT'S A TECHNICAL
ISSUE OR THE RESULT OF A LAW
ENFORCEMENT ACTION.
THE FBI DISCOURAGES BUT DOES NOT
BAN AMERICAN COMPANIES LIKE
COLONIAL FROM PAYING A RANSOM.
THE BUREAU WARNS THERE IS NO
GUARANTEE THE COMPANY WILL GET
ITS DATA BACK AND SAYS THE
PAYMENTS ONLY ENCOURAGE MORE
CYBER ATTACKS IN THE FUTURE.
COLONIAL PIPELINE IS NAVIGATING
UNCHARTED TERRITORY.
THIS IS THE FIRST TIME THE
ENTIRE PIPELINE RUNNING 5,500
MILES WAS SHUT DOWN, AND THE
COMPANY SAYS FULLY RESTARTING
THE DELIVERY SUPPLY CHAIN WILL
TAKE TIME BECAUSE IT'S PUTTING
SAFETY FIRST.
ACCORDING TO GAS BUDDY, 15
STATES AND THE DISTRICT OF
COLUMBIA HAVE REPORTED DRY GAS
STATIONS.
SPEAKING FROM THE WHITE HOUSE,
PRESIDENT BIDEN SEEMED TO TEMPER
EXPECTATIONS SAYING THE PIPELINE
IS NOT LIKE FLICKING A SWITCH.
AND HE ALSO WARNED GAS STATIONS
AGAINST PRICE GOUGING.
AND WHILE PIRESIDENT BIDEN SAID
HE DOES NOT BELIEVE VLADIMIR
PUTIN'S GOVERNMENT WAS DIRECTLY
INVOLVED, HE SAID THERE IS
REASON TO BELIEVE THE HACKERS
ARE LIVING IN RUSSIA AND URGED
MOSCOW T